I've worked hard to get here but Barbara
changed my life and she made me a
household name she had a wonderful
wicked sense of humor and she supported
me in everything I did came to every
show that I did uh she just was
supportive and loving and funny Sheri
Shepard reflects on Barbara Walters
Legacy and how the broadcasting icon
changed her life from the bottom of my
heart to all of you with whom I have
worked and to all of you who have
watched and been at my side for so many
years I can say thank you maybe instead
of goodbye I should take a deep breath
and enjoy my view on December 30th
Barbara died at the age of 93 and for
Sherry it all came as a shock she was
like a thud in my heart it was extreme
sadness but joy at being able to be such
in in such a Monumental show I think
because the year that I came on leaned
into politics so when you see all of the
clips of the politicians coming out like
I'm sitting right there next to Barbara
so being extremely grateful that I was
allowed to be a part of her sphere you
know for such a long time Sherry started
out on The View as a guest co-host in
2006. the gig turned permanent the
following year and turns out Barbara was
a big reason why first of all Barbara
had to fight to get me on the show
alongside Whoopi the network didn't want
me because at that time they thought
that you know all African-Americans were
monolithic and they're thinking that we
were going to say the same thing think
alike and Whoopi and I couldn't have
been more opposite in our thoughts so
she fought to have two black women at
the table now it's par for the course
you see you you gotta show like the real
which is all women of color but
um that right there is what I remember
about Barbara just fighting for me to be
on this show and believing in me and
defending me ferociously when I would
make mistakes as for the biggest lesson
Sherry learned while working with
Barbara this politician to come and she
said why didn't you speak and I said
because you ain't answer question and
Whoopi and she said speak up or be left
behind
and that's when I learned now you can't
get me to shut up
um but I learned to speak up you know
sometimes you can't follow the rules you
got to take risks you got to be fearless
and that's what I learned from Barbara
be curious be Fearless don't take no for
an answer and when it came to life off
camera the ladies had a close Bond and
Barbara she wasn't afraid to talk Hot
Topics at home what you saw on the show
versus one-on-one with Barbara
completely different whenever like I
said on The View whenever Barb would say
I want to have dinner with you dude I
want to have dinner with you dear I was
like what did I do now we would go out
to dinner hold hands laugh so much we
talked about sex non-stop she gave me
marriage advice literally Barbara said
you always get with men who take your
money don't get married anymore you need
to become a lesbian but nothing she said
come to think of it a lesbian would
probably take your money too so I mean
that was like Barbara she had a
wonderful Wicked it sense of humor and
she supported me in everything I did
came to every show that I did she just
was supportive and loving and funny you
know if you're doing something and
Barbara saw it you always got a
handwritten note that's one thing that I
learned from Barbara I got a thousand
cars that say Sherry that you know
handwritten notes are really important
so it wasn't that she would call it was
that you would get a note in the mail
saying I support you you were lovely
darling I have those notes you know
still that Barbara sent me as for
Barbara's Legacy Sherry says she's left
a long lasting impact you know every
show that has a panel is an offshoot of
The View when you hear talk shows with
the and the and the noun behind it or
the adjective The Chew the real the talk
every ESPN panel that is an offshoot of
Barbara show The View was the first and
the fact that she was Fearless she was
undeterred people said no she flew
around the country and met every
affiliate herself individually so they
could put the show in the air two black
women historical that had never been
done on a talk show so Barbara was the
first any journalist anybody who says to
you what's your energy like anybody who
tries to make you cry anybody who has
the Deep that's Barbara I sit there on
my show with no cards really trying to
listen to the that's all Barbara
so wow what a legacy